a lot of the time you arrive somewhere
realize that they don't have the same
plug that you do and that you don't have
enough converter plugs you just need one
converter plug and a multi socket to
take with you so i now have a eight gang
five meter multi socket that lives in my
suitcase and then you just need a single
converter and that's eight plugs that
you can use
i bet someone listening to this will
message in and say that that is not a
safe thing to do i've done it for ages
oh it doesn't mean it's safe
i've not had any problems i don't know
what you're talking about i've not
encountered
an n of one here has bro sciences way
through all of these issues
i am going to texas
for a while
this friday
uh i'm gonna fly to austin
and spend a few weeks out there
which is gonna be fun because the last
18 months have basically been the same
day lived over and over again i i
elected to essentially extend my
quarantine because i created a routine
that i haven't been able to get myself
back out of even though the rest of the
world opened back up i just looked at
the same
yeah i think for three of us like we we
have just lived the same day
yeah
over and over again
i just need to break it man so yeah i'm
uh i'm gonna go to austin
i for some reason when i imagine you in
austin
you just always have the the cowboy hat
you think i'm going to appropriate
austin texan culture very quickly yeah
like holsters
leather holsters and big like snake skin
boots and those kind of suede belt
buckle
underwood from house of cards was he
from texas
i think he's supposed to be there's like
a an undertone of
texas accent something about him he
when that scandal went on and he just
doubled down
what and then he got he privately
like created his own
dvd extra for anyone that doesn't know
what we're talking about the guy that
plays frank underwood who is called
kevin spacey kevin spacey he after 18
months after a huge scandal got released
that was the reason that he no longer
did house of cards
he then created
uh
as the character in-house of cards
a semi-fourth wall break referring to
the camera fully edited and cinematic
with music and stuff but just done off
his own back and it just appeared out of
nowhere on the internet and then no one
really spoke about it again and now no
one knows where he is and that's it
i can't bear to imagine the legal
implicate like copyright and all that
stuff of just yeah
remaining in character to be honest i
think that he's probably got bigger
problems
from a jurisdiction perspective i think
that there are larger issues at play
just throw it in the pot you know what i
mean his lawyer just like oh frank
it's not frank that's the point yeah
he's not supposed to be frank so i'm
going to go out there and i'm going to
be like frank underwood but
michael mallis is out there aubry marcus
is out there lex friedman's out there
jocko willink is in town a week on
saturday oh my god which will be pretty
cool so i think i'm going to go and see
him well i'll do some pull-ups at 4am
with him it'll just be good won't it
yeah everything will be good [ __ ]
good
are you gonna are you gonna meet all of
them is that the plan i don't well i
mean jocko's got a live show on i've
tweeted i've just tweeted him recently
um so i'll try and get him on the show
because we were talking about it a while
back um you might go again go on man
he's serious eh um
aubry i'm
living my airbnb is 10 minutes walk from
on it hq uh it's also 10 minutes from
kuya do you remember i had that dr dan
angle the guy that did mbma therapy on
so his new place in austin which does
cold and hot treatments and floatation
tanks and mdma assisted psychotherapy
and stuff all of that it's just a
playground so those sound like three
quite different things like
i mean
it would be you'd be tempted wouldn't
you just do it all at once she'd be like
right do you know what to do
give me the platinum package
i mean yeah
it would i assume it'd be quite
traumatic
rather than it's not like it's not gonna
be like a nice relaxing experience no
i'm pretty sure you're not supposed to
do them all together i think that's
that's almost definitely the rule but
yeah so zach tallander is going to pick
me up on friday which is nice annoyingly
because i took one extra day to
gesticulate about which airbnb i was
going to get
i
someone booked one night in the airbnb
of the night that i arrived so i can
still book it for the entirety of my
trip without having to move however the
first night i'm going to have to spoon
zach so i need to i'm getting picked up
by him and like
and play little play a little spoon for
the evening
what's the thing you are most looking
forward to
change of routine man
the last 18 months has just been i don't
have a particularly good routine here
that
the main thing that i've realized over
the last 18 months is that there is more
to life than completing tasks on your
to-do list
yeah very hard to get out of that
they're just and because it's so
inherently enjoyable there is something
that is really really enjoyable
about
completing the things that were in front
of you because for ages you were never
able to complete them and now you keep
on going and you keep on going
but you realize it's kind of too much of
a good thing because you do that at the
mercy
you sacrifice i mean how much have we
obviously we've had a pandemic and stuff
we've barely seen each other apart we've
seen each other more on podcasts than
outside of them over the last 18 months
which is pretty scandalous well even the
podcast used to be
all of them used to be in person on your
and it would be an entire evening and
there'd be better before and better
yeah so i just think there's been some
you get into rhythms and routines of
living so
where i'm living i'm next to the gym
that i'm going to train at which is
atomic athlete uh i'm 10 minutes from on
it which is where christian and skye and
max and aubry and all of the people that
look after his stuff
10 minutes from david perrell 15 minutes
from michael mallis like loads of people
there different food different training
different stimulus i think i'm gonna go
hunting one weekend so it's just gonna
be all of the stuff that i do now is
still the same show still three times a
week
with some extra in persons but
everything outside of the show should
change so yeah it's i need a refresh
it's been
it's been successful the last 18 months
has been good but you there's always a
price to pay and i think so
sanity and
um
boredom or monotony would be more
accurate cause it's not being boredom
but it has been monotony it'd be
interesting to see what you what it does
to like your because i suppose you
i can't think of anyone that's doing
what you're doing that you would meet in
person
regularly
that's like ahead of you
maybe you know someone but like
certainly in in newcastle it's not like
the the hub of last time would have been
going to london to see ali abdal that
was probably it
um yeah
but you are you're throwing yourself
into a place where there'll be a lot of
people who are doing some pretty cool
things yeah it's so little fish in big
pond time again no which i'm quite
looking forward to actually i think
you'll be more productive in the time
that you are working as well like
whenever you have a shift of scene
you're not in the kind of
slug mode of the same desk and in the
kind of inertia feeling when you're like
even even like literally going to the
local library or coffee shop or
something it's enough to just be like
right i'm in a different environment now
yeah if you've got a timetable of events
coming up you're always going to
complete your work to give you time to
be able to go and do the events whereas
when you've got [ __ ] all going on at
home you just it's parkinson's law like
run amok you just expand your work out
and now and then even if you complete
the tasks well i'll just put another
task on my plate it's fine i've got
nothing to do tonight i'll just keep
working i'll just keep working i'll just
keep working whereas if jocko's live
show's on at 6 p.m and i know that i
need to leave i think right well i need
to get this edit done or i need to get
these emails finished up whatever it is
so yes i'm going to be in texas so if
there is anyone that thinks that i
should meet up with people that are out
there just tweet me or or leave a
comment below or something like that and
i'll try and uh
i'll try it's got more adventures gotta
be joe broken surely the number of
people they're the person to meet up
with the number of people that have
messaged and said dude you're going on
rogan am i i don't think you realize
just how big the delta is between joe
rogan and everybody else it's very
flattering for people to be like oh my
god are you going on uh but no i mean i
maybe malice if malice goes out for
dinner and the stars align he was out
for dinner the other night with
michael mallis lex friedman joe rogan
and alex jones
um
what a dinner [ __ ]
you've got one one from each of the food
groups sat around that table um so
but i don't know man we'll see it's just
there's a lot of serendipity i think so
it'll be cool and if nothing else
michaela and jordan are in nashville in
a couple of weeks time so i'm going to
go and see them uh so i'm probably going
to spend it take a weekend in flat
douglas murray is in town hold on hold
on you're going to go and meet jordan
peterson
i think so yeah in nashville because i
would have met i just i feel like you've
just washed over that snippet
i mean if
i rewind when you first
heard of jordan peterson if someone said
that you're going to be like going and
spending some time with them actually
casually dropping the fact that you get
to go and see me
when i ask you what's the thing you're
looking forward to most you're like oh
well you know it'll be nice to not be at
work from a different place and
yeah okay
yeah that's what i would like maybe that
shows i've spent a lot of time getting
to know mick and and
so talk to him a fair bit as well so
maybe that's douglas murray as well he's
going to be floating around so i might
get to see him i want to get a gym
session with douglas murray that's going
to be quite funny anyway that's enough
that's enough
incline
so it's a lifx episode today
i'll be in texas soon but this episode
needs to happen right now
so johnny what life hacks have you got
for us
i i think i have one of the
it's at least the list i'm the least
excited to share
how's that for luring everyone
really
just
wind us up let us go come on
so
a few of mine are
a bit niche
i don't know whether that's okay
the one i wanted to be one i wanted to
be one i've wanted to share for a while
which is very niche
and i think chris my laugher is a
bar
velocity tracker
have i shared this before no but i know
that you talk about it so so i guess for
anybody who
[Music]
i mean any olympic lifting and certainly
any power lifters
anyone who tracks their trait they're
trading in the gym
this is a
a little black device little black piece
of plastic i think they're 3d printed
they're really weird looking things made
by a company called rep one
you attach this wire to a barbell
that magnetically attaches to a plate or
to the power rack or whatever and it
basically just measures what the bar is
doing in space it tells you how fast the
bar is moving
um the nice thing about it is
firstly you can predict what you can do
which is really cool so you can you know
what way you'd be able to lift on a
certain day but also it's just another
way of tracking progress because anybody
who's been training for any length of
time knows that it does it does get
harder and harder over time to just keep
adding weight to the bar but you can
just get a 0.05
speed
improvement over time so they are quite
expensive it's probably something that
how much is unless you think they're
about 300 it's 350 dollars
so it depends on the exchange rate at
the time and what's the app like
really good
interface is pretty slick yeah i mean
it's a really small company so there's
normally a like a backlog you have to
wait for them
but if you can get your hands on one and
you care about anything like this i
think i've probably i was thinking about
this the other day
it'll be into the thousands of reps that
i've tracked with it now wow so it's
it's pretty like if i i'll do a warm-up
set and it with pretty good
accuracy can predict what i can do on
that day wow so i just don't have to
think about it that's crazy that's cool
so is that
these things do you use it as kind of a
gauge for rpe
yeah so i do what you're not really
supposed to do which is i kind of now
ignore rpe and i just look at the bar
speed
because i know like over time
if i do something and if i do a bench
and it's 0.21 meters per second that's
that's an rp8
so i just look at the bar speed [ __ ] man
this is so cool like this is
post rpe rpe
but you're not so so my coach tells me
off right you're not supposed to do that
you're supposed to still have like a
feel element but
like everyone's been under a barbell
where it subjectively looks really hard
and you might like maybe someone you
stand up and someone goes oh that look
really easy like it wasn't really easy
so i think you lose some of the the
ability to actually measure it when you
it's happening to you but as if you just
rely on the the speed of it then it can
be it can be very humbling because like
you go into into the gym you don't want
to train and your warm-up set was faster
than last week you're like
god's sake like
here we go yeah
but yeah so if if you're into any
strength sport or you train with
barbells regularly you like tracking
your progress you like graphs and charts
and all that sort of stuff highly highly
recommend it
it's i've had over a year of use out of
mine and it's brilliant
it's called the rep one device
nice there we go um just to add to that
i think
it's always worth paying for this kind
of thing if there is something if you
train for strength and you care about
improving a particular metric and
there is something
that you can buy that will help you
achieve that goal and even if you can
attribute a five kilogram gain on your
squat to that device over a year
like
that's well worth it compared to all the
other stuff that we spend
hundreds of pounds on like i don't know
creatine and yeah i'm gonna say
supplements new pairs of lifters some
weird new sleep masks and acupressure
mats to help your parasympathetic system
there we go there's so much that you
whereas this is directly attributable
right i can actually see that that has
resulted in
knowing whether i'm progressing and
improving that
so
today's life hack for me i don't know if
you guys know this but um
the the way that i like to kind of
divide my my life hacks is really
physical and digital
so
to start with this is actually a hybrid
is to digitize photos
so
about five or six years ago my dad died
and we had to clear out the house and we
had loads of photo albums from like
literally from like 1970s
up until recently and they'd all been
physically printed onto
photo albums and filed away
and it was boxes and boxes of it and we
were thinking like how first of all no
one's got the space to store this stuff
and secondly what you're going to do
with a bunch of physical photo albums
like how often do you sit and like flick
through them and we found a company
that
digitizes
documents and they just scan in bulk
so and they were fantastic they were
called clear data
and you just give them the boxes
they have like a proper
almost like a warehouse
factory with loads of people that take
the things out of the sleeves and scan
it through the thing
and they send you a sample and they're
like are you happy with how this is
going to look and you're like yep great
and they keep you informed all along the
process
and it was like 800 quid or something to
do
9 000 photos which i think holy [ __ ]
i think is is worth it like that is such
a good deal
and that's someone taking each photo out
of its little so i think what actually
what we did was um we went through them
and like threw away all the crap ones
and then roommate
the 9000 were like the the pick of the
crop and so we gave them in boxes to
them
they did it and then just
sent me a usb stick with a password and
that was it it was just like that is the
entire like
scone family memories yeah you said
boxes and boxes and boxes of things and
a thumb drive came back that happened to
have them all on replicable for the rest
of day
it was really it was one of those
moments where you you realize how far
technology's come because we take it for
granted don't move that you like usb
stick you know i'll just
be like god that is
everything i suppose you you don't often
see like a physical
representation of what's on a usb stick
like if you had to print off the pages
of everything on a usb stick and sit
next to you'd be like okay
like that
there was a crazy a stat that i saw that
said the amount of data that is created
on the internet every day if you printed
it out double-sided on a4 paper it would
make a stack that went to the sun and
back every single day that's how much
data was created stack if you said not
if you lined up no no yeah so just put
them down like you would do a normal
stack of paper one on top of each other
it would go to the sun and back every
single day
my my like gut reaction to that is that
that's not sustainable
it's like something's gonna happen
there's also a stat around
so you have all of the server space
across the planet right which is holding
the data but the actual electrons that
make up the data itself
if you combined all of those together it
would be smaller than the size of an
orange
and that's all the data all the data
smaller than orange just come and get my
head around it mental right my one my
one i've got loads of good life hacks
first one is if you're buying stuff from
asos because they have free returns and
because if you spend more than a hundred
or this is one of the og life hacks yes
i don't think it's been featured man
yeah johnny should have done it so
basically order if you're not sure about
your sizing on asos because delivery is
free over i want to say 100 or 150
pounds and returns are free and you get
between
it's like 60 days it's quite a generous
it's a long time uh exchange policy uh
our return policy just buy everything in
every different size that you think that
you might want to bump you up and over
the 150 get free next day delivery
you've also got free returns plus you
know that you're going to find the size
that you want and if you're in in
between sizes you also know that rather
than doing it in two batches of 50
pounds or something or two batches of 75
pounds having to pay for shipping
potentially twice and not having it all
at one go just buy everything from asos
and then
send it back
so i use the
like they have like an ai
shop assistant where you put some
measurements in and it like predicts
what your size will be i ordered like
five or six things and it was a hundred
percent if it was wrong
so
i had to send everything back
because that's what i messaged you
saying like how do you deal with this
and you said that hack is
what measurements did you do you have to
send like inner thigh measurement and
stuff or was it just like no i don't
think so i can't remember you also have
broken the system your inner thighs will
be beyond maximum yeah
so yeah i mean it was all just like
slightly too big or slightly too small
like it could have all passed but
in the shop if you were trying on the
shop you wouldn't try it on ago yeah
it's fine like i need the other size but
this one will do like you would go and
change it i think that that site if if
if you're wearing something that's like
oh it's a bit small but i think it'll
pass
it's not take it back yeah and like
especially especially if the only thing
that's stopping you is like i've got to
put it back in the bag and i was bullied
and sent back with everything else
that's it easy right johnny what else
um
so mine this next one is i think the
opposite of what yusuf does for
everything
in this category which is i already love
it to sign up when you're signing up for
a service or
an app or anything like that
to do it monthly and never get the bulk
um
option
reason being when you get billed
every month it's a prompt and a reminder
of like am i still using this so you're
always using the fewest things
because it's happened to me once before
where
you
just get hit with an apple bill of like
39.99 you're like what what on earth is
that and then you realize it's like an
annual subscription you sign up to a
year ago and you kind of don't really
use the app anymore well that's and that
sort of thing so anything that you and
what are some examples of these things
that you've got so anything so like so
rom what is probably the the best
example of this like i
signed up for that initially yearly
because i was using all the time
yusuf told me that i was gonna snap my
back if i continue using not not really
but like all the stuff you guys were
trying to see mcgill and it was a bad
idea and all sorts of stuff stopped
using it and i still had like
eight months of the year left
right so that's that's an example so
anything
um
just any any app i suppose the only
exceptions are stuff that you are
absolutely sold that you are not going
to stop using so something like netflix
for example or can you play that yearly
i feel like you can only pay that money
yeah probably not amazon prime you can
pay yearly for example
i think i agree with that like the only
thing that i that i do is
put in a so as soon as i sign up for
anything if i'm not sure i'm going to
keep it i'll just put in a reminder in
my tick tick command shift o
yeah on like five days before give
myself a bit of grace period not like
the day of that it's actually renewed
because otherwise like if you don't
catch it yeah immediately you [ __ ]
you're getting done because with a lot
of apps there's the the clause of like
if you log into it after the
subscriptions
come out they don't like apple have a
really strict refund policy well you
knew about it for a year so why is it
suddenly an emergency yeah and
i agree as well that's what i would say
but you don't wait till the day after
you get billed to go i want to cancel
the vast majority of apps as well that
you use they do have a shelf life you
get bored after a while or you feel like
you pick up all the low-hanging fruit
from this
breathwork
membership or whatever optimize.me
brian's thing we've all been through
that or a blinkist membership or
yeah whatever
um yeah i always think i like that it's
more flexible right yeah but everyone
has that like period of enthusiasm with
it we're like oh this is it like this is
the app this is the only app i'll ever
need for this i'm going to i'll sign up
yearly because i save money but actually
i think a lot of the time
you end up either getting rebuild an
error that you didn't you didn't want to
get rebuild or you
don't use it as much as you think you
will and the monthly email going you've
been billed is enough to prompt you to
go i'm going to cancel that
nice
seth
this is a physical one
i have been
looking for a way to routinely
clean my bathroom and i found like i
think it's the i don't know if it's hard
or soft water that gives you the lime
scale
in a toilet
hard
um so
yeah so i've got this like descaler
thing and you have to pour in the toilet
you have to remember to use it every
like a couple of weeks and then you
leave it for 10 minutes and scrape out
the thing and it's a bit of a ball leg
so
recently i've started buying toilet
system pucks
which are the little blue circle things
flush blue
yeah like every old woman in the world
has one and you put it in your system
it's brilliant it lasts for like six
weeks it gives you a nice blue toilet
and everything's just handled just
bleaches it every day for you
so you put it in the it's not one of
those ones that like hangs down in the
bowl
so it's called a like rim guard or
something um it's not
it's just something
no one's allowed that word
[Laughter]
right guys let's uh we got the marketing
meeting for the new uh
the new domestos toilet
jonathan you've got a good you've got a
great name for this haven't you yeah
we've come up with rim guard
it's called rim block
that's even worse
but no that so this goes into the
cistern which is the back i suppose okay
one extra life hack just off the back of
that because i remember seeing this
because the system like the whole point
of it is that it drip feeds whatever's
in it through your toilet is the um i
saw somewhere that if you if someone's
upset you
you can poo in their cistern
and then every time they fly a little
bit
yeah and they just can't work out where
it's coming from never a lot of people i
wonder i actually think i actually think
that probably that that's not as
logistically difficult as you might
think take the lid off feet on the bowl
yeah
sit on
it's just doing a poo but one level up
isn't it it is it's a it's a level two
poo
it's not a ground floor poo
it's not i don't want to the problems
you'd have is your feet would be closer
together so that would feel strange and
i think i bet the system's not as stable
as you think
yeah that's true and and you wouldn't be
able to use your squatty potty and i'm
fully sold on my squatty potty now you
haven't spoken about that
really oh no yes no sorry ally ally
allied in the first life to unkink the
rectal shelf
[Laughter]
very important so someone actually
posted today saying like
if you're
wiping more than three times for a poo
something wrong with your diet and i
responded saying
that's that's sometimes true but also it
could be a technique issue like if
you're optimistically trying to trying
to
squeeze out a second one after like
you've done a pristine log and you what
you're thinking like how do i like
but it's not fully and then you have to
just be like oh right a board i'll cut
it off yeah that you can't you can't be
doing that you've got to just commit to
a good one and say right if there's
anything leave it there for the day
yeah we're done all right uh what am i
gonna do this is a very johnny one
actually
this is i've realized because i'm
i've tumbled into into intermittent
fasting because of how much time i spent
talking to dr david sinclair earlier
this year and a lot of the time i
haven't eaten probably until about 2 or
3 p.m
i go through my day and do things when
i'm hungry and shopping when you're
hungry is just a recipe for things to go
terribly wrong
so
thankfully in most british supermarkets
at least they have the convenience
sandwich aisle directly at the front
so the best way i've found to just nerf
take the edge off this is to buy a
sandwich so go in go into the sandwich
go into the supermarket get a sandwich
aim for around about is it 15
of the calories from some 10 of the
calories from protein
and just eat the sandwich
as quick well as you're walking around
but relatively quickly and it'll just
curb your hunger cravings so you won't
end up going to the confectionary aisle
and buying tons of stuff that you don't
need and throwing it in
so this is if your eating window has
just started and you're going shopping
correct
to be honest i think
given the choice between
breaking your eating window a little bit
earlier and buying a ton of junk that
you don't need from the supermarket
that's just monster munch yeah exactly
it's you're
losing you're paying the lesser of the
two costs so yeah just have a sandwich
if you're hungry and you get to the
supermarket and this is you know not
everyone's intermittent fasting if
you're hungry and you get to the
supermarket just buy a sandwich it'll be
two pounds 50 which will be far less
than the 10 pounds of junk that you're
going to buy plus you're not going to
have all of that [ __ ] in your house
anymore it's
perfect i can't believe that i've never
done it before
i
people should just eat more sandwiches
in general i think they're absolutely
fantastic you are a connoisseur yeah
they're brilliant
what's your top what's your top three
sandwiches
that anybody
could buy right three sandwiches that i
can buy right now
from a supermarket yeah or or from a
high street okay so instead of that i'll
rank i'll rank if you've got to buy a
slam which you're out you're out in town
you need to get a sandwich where should
you go yeah good question but i want to
know what sandwich from each place
specifically yes so anything any
anything from the m s sandwich section
is pretty much always very good
and anything with chicken in so the
chicken and bacon
is like a chicken club it's a chicken
caesar salad one all very very good
it's a really steep drop off after that
unfortunately so
[Laughter]
waitrose you'd think but that sounds
nice very disappointing
sainsbury's tesco they're okay
and i wouldn't even i wouldn't even look
anywhere else to be honest really we
need to do a special audition episode of
sandwiches you're like such a sandwich
snob are you not i think we need to
follow johnny round
and just i think just to see what johnny
can do to a sandwich like it's
terrifying did you see that the guy that
started bar stool sports el presidente
did you see that he does one part one
bite pizza reviews
just has one one mouthful one
one bite of a pizza and gives his review
and it's really famous and he goes
around the entire country he goes all
over america
doing one bite pizza reviews and there's
an app as well you can download an app
that gives you his feedback it's a
proper cult following i just don't think
it bites enough to fully review it i
think it's called one bite pizza review
though so i know committed
could you not do a one bite sandwich
review
read the entire sandwich yeah yeah just
a sandwich review
i think i could do
i reckon most sandwiches in see i don't
want to i don't commit myself to a time
because i can imagine i'll end up having
to actually do this but i would say
two minutes
i'm sure you were a three
in the time that i was halfway through
one i think you are on the slow end of
it you eat painfully slowly that's why
normal yeah this is why whenever we go
out for dinner
you always buy a little bit less than
you know that you need to eat because
you know that you'll still be eating
when everyone else has hit their limit
of how much they're going to eat and
then you go
um is that have you got any more of that
are you not going to finish uh
oh you're sure
are you sure and then you go are you
sure i hadn't noticed that all the time
it's a [ __ ] tactic it's strategic
we're going out for dinner on wednesday
so watch what happens watch he'll get a
quarter chicken and then finish mining
your meals
yeah
there's just very i very rarely leave it
leave anything sometimes leave some
sources i'll sometimes over overdo it on
the sources or a dirty africato okay so
is that m s waitrose some sainsburys
i go tesco over say tesco tesco next
then probably sainsbury's but if you can
get into a waitress that's why whenever
we go anywhere i'm really excited about
the mms simply food
good
because we go to like weatherby services
like i would go out of my way
i would i would go a slower route if it
meant going viral
as we went to go and see bring me the
horizon
with
free
ticketed access from the band you were
more excited about the prospect of going
via weatherby services
because you wanted to go into the m s
food hall
that was it was brilliant
it was great we did well yeah that was
really yeah i mean the band were fine
but they haven't essentially sandwiches
that's what we're here the number of
percy pig variants now as well they're
pushing it too far they've pushed it
back they've pushed it too far if
anything
uh right like you said joseph come on
it's me oh it's you it is you do a
double
no no i didn't i never had one
yeah you just asked him about science
judges yes i'm happy for sandwiches to
be my life hack because i i really agree
with that at an
emotional level visceral level um so i
wasn't going to say this one but this is
it's not really a life hack it's more
just a nice thing that you can also get
from m s that's percy pig themed
which is
percy pig ice cream
which has better macros
well
it's lower calorie
than well same ballpark as halo top
so it could come in huge vats
and it's got like marshmallows and
raspberry sauce and vanilla and
strawberry ice cream like pink and white
swirls
well it's really the overall flavor
vanilla and strawberry i would say
so i had when i snapped my achilles last
year my friend adam came around and
delivered me
something
from m s that was ice cream in a pink
tub and it was bright pink it wasn't
swirly but i i
swear it was
i swear it was percy pig wasn't swirly
it wasn't a swirly so
it's evolved over time
have i maybe got the wrong type you've
got like the beta percy pig the [ __ ] one
because that was awful i couldn't even i
know it was [ __ ] terrible
i was about to fight you did it did it
taste like percy pigs
no it just tasted it just tasted like
frozen sugar
frozen sugar mixed with
mixed with strawberry milk it was awful
but it's not like broadly i mean i've
i've got a sweet tooth man i'll i'll
tell you if something's nice when it's
sweet and that was [ __ ] [ __ ]
but you don't like halo top d
yeah i'm fine with taylor top i prefer
muforia
oh yeah who i mean who doesn't
ben and jerry's move forward i mean that
yeah i mean
could do a life hacks on just sweet
foods i think
before he's brilliant uh so
you're saying
percy pig's ice cream so it's like it's
a hidden low calorie ice cream
is is the the hack so you would never
assume
i'm gonna go to mms and get some percy
pick ice cream like you immediately
think that is gonna be this like
decadent super high calorie thing it's
actually
on par with hair it doesn't have the
protein content but like
i don't think that's why you're eating
the ice cream in the first place so
you can have i mean i have eaten an
entire tub of this stuff before and it
is
very mechanically full at the end of
it's this but like 600 calories
what for a full tub
yeah wow
and it's a bigger tub than halo top it's
like yeah yeah it'll be a proper bucket
it's like a family serving across
multiple weeks
and i was like that looks like pudding
nice
i think last lifehacks then if it was
back in june
we were getting excited about
the ios update that has live text
recognition
so
now it's out and it is fantastic like
it's really so what what it does is
allows you in
basically system wide
to recognize text in images so that's
known as ocr optical character
recognition i think
so if you have a photo in your album of
text or a sign or whatever you can
literally just drag and select the text
as you would with anything
copy it into your notes or whatever
what you can also do
is
when you're typing so let's say open up
an apple note while you're listening to
this
tap on the cursor under like a barcode
type
image comes up
a square with some lines press on that
and then just hold it over
a page in a book
and it'll recognize all the text
instantly and then you can just tap on
the button and it just inserts that
entire page as text
into your apple note
i've just i've just done it there and
it's it's
it's put text everywhere
all over the place i don't think i use
it i don't think i don't think i would
use it either if i'm honest
if you're reading a physical book and
you're like oh when i just capture a
couple of highlights or notes from that
yeah okay that's not
yeah that's that's not bad i suppose
that wouldn't it depends on whether or
not you read on kindle as much because
almost everything that i read is
electronic now
um
then it sinks into you think yeah yeah
there's probably there's probably some
very inventive use cases of this feature
that
like we've not really thought of i think
it lays the ground for some exciting
stuff i'm trying to think about
letters
and correspondence and stuff like that
but all of that probably just needs a
scan it just needs a microsoft lens joby
doesn't it and or
evernote whatever and just saving down
somewhere receipts it works for uh
handwriting as well though
so if you're a student and you you like
to hand write notes but
is your handwriting terrible brutal one
it'll convert it into like a notes file
into text text on screen yeah
is there anything that because i still
use scannable for evernote can i
how do i get get like a
i don't know an important offline
physical document into apple notes
so when you're in
when you're on your mac right click and
just choose scan document and it
activates your phone if it's nearby in
scan mode you can just hold it over the
thing okay
that's reduced real life pack you don't
even need to press like yes okay it'll
just
locate when when there's a page and just
send it into your thing on your mac and
does it does it do as the scannable app
does where it will like
almost like it turns up the contrast and
finds the edges and all that stuff yeah
how do you do that
so right click and say scan document you
can do it in an email in a note
and
the continuity is just delightful
it's really what locks you in from ever
getting like an android phone
yeah
oh my god it's just done
[Laughter]
desperately searching for some documents
to scan wow
i love how that wasn't even the like
[ __ ]
we've just that's just the bonus yeah
the bonus hack that came with that
bonus round uh okay i've got so many
good ones i don't know what to do okay
so
um
this is for anyone that's a freelancer
or anyone that does
bits of work
uh
outside of their main job or someone
that just needs to negotiate rates that
doesn't have a classic set rate for
whatever it is that they do
so there's always this weird
dance that you do this sort of tango
backward and forward a client comes to
you and says hey man someone's friend
let's say that you design websites or
that you teach people to play football
or whatever someone comes to you and
says
hey mate i've got this job um i i need
you to
x what what what's your price for
building a website or for doing a
weekend course for 15 year olds that
want to play football in a team or
whatever it is that you do coach someone
to get lean for a competition and
there's always this sort of
bizarre standoffish backwards and
forwards game that you're playing
because you
don't know what their budget range is
they don't probably know what yours is
unless they're quite familiar with what
it is that you do so getting yourself
into the same universe is quite
difficult so you can often pitch your
price at that time
something that you think it might be but
you don't want to pitch it so high that
they say no and you don't pitch it so
low if they say yes instantly you
immediately feel like you've [ __ ]
yourself so for instance i did this i
did this a few years ago someone had
asked the price for me to do something
and i'd come back with the price and
they'd said yes instantly uh first hack
is if someone says that
immediately say plus that because if
they said yes you can easily add twenty
percent
i think just to do
that's a very
someone said yes
straight away and you go
plus that then you've got 20 on top but
you've already undercharged so what
you're trying to avoid is a situation
where you undercharge so much that the
person just comes back so your answer
should be
what's the budget
that's the question that you should ask
in response hi mate can you do this
thing for me oh yeah sure i mean
obviously i i want to make this work but
it's got to work for both of us like
what what's the what's the sort of
budget that you guys are trying to hit
they will tend to come back usually
around about 10 to 20 percent below what
their actual maximum budget is so they
won't come in with their real budget but
at least you know the ballpark that
you're talking about and if it's
50 of what you usually charge your
timeout at then you say look like
there's there's no really conversation
to be had here and if you are talking
about that a lot of the time especially
if it's corporate clients
their budget is way way higher than your
time is actually worth
so by asking them what the budget is you
can usually go to quite easily that you
know exactly what a minimum acceptable
price would be and you can probably push
it a little bit more maybe add some
expenses on
job done
thing is morally reprehensible
like how do you try and squeeze as much
extract as much uh money from someone as
possible i don't think that's the way to
do business chris
the principle is
like the extension from that is in any
negotiation you don't you don't say your
number first
yeah so i'd have to factor in
the ball lake of me getting a new one
because i don't it's not for sale i
don't want to have to buy a new one
so i'd have to straight away you're on
the back foot he's like god what do i
say here like i don't know i don't know
five pounds
plus that what's that yes six pounds yes
now see you've just made an extra pound
i don't see how that's morally
i don't want an extra pound
what you've done there is like you've
taken advantage of somebody
somebody's willingness to just be a
simple customer no no no i've taken i've
offset me undercharging that person they
wouldn't have said yes so quickly that's
your problem for under charging in the
first place i'm now no longer under
charging them anymore because of that
well
what about if they say
okay can i have your vat details i say
uh sorry mate not got no not got those
by the way you're paying it in my
personal account
all right
also not that registered
if the hmrc are listening that's
obviously this entire
sequence has been
a huge joke
and dramatized yeah and the company that
i'm talking about is now now defunct and
closed down in any case
nothing to do with chris uh johann what
have you got
me
me now
um
this we've probably i feel like we've
probably said this but i've had this on
my lifehacks list for ages
it's it might be something you both do
but i'd be interested to hear your
answer to it
i feel like
the
cornerstone
of a day if i like feel like i'm on top
of stuff or i'm not on top of stuff
the difference the thing that i do that
helps me feel on top of stuff is empty
my
omnifocus inbox to zero
so i like throw stuff in it
all the time
and it just builds and builds and builds
and builds
and there'll be like little things that
i assume are tomorrow i'll empty my
inbox and i'll i'll do that thing it'll
take me a couple of minutes i'll send
that message or whatever as long as i
zero that
everything's fine
if i don't zero it firstly i lose trust
in the whole process
and secondly i just miss things things
get pushed back so that the hack is just
if you follow any kind of like
gtd getting things done capture process
i think the even more important habit is
don't let things
fester in your in your inbox for more
than more than a day
when you say you're doing that is that
you go through and do the items or you
put them into the relevant
well that's the existential schedule so
the process of like if it's a less than
two minute thing just do it says like
send this message or apply this or send
this to someone
uh or in omnifocus which is obviously
the the best app available you would put
it in
the correct project
so you like get it out of the inbox so
you are okay this needs to be done this
week i'll allocate it to a day this
needs to be done
on a date
this i need to be reminded about this in
a month it needs to be just put in a
project i'll review it later
but it needs to be like put in the
appropriate place but like by by just
going through the inbox the number you
end up having done like eight things
that were like little bitty things that
you probably wouldn't set time aside to
do
but if you have the task of well every
day i zero it then you end up doing it
anyway so is the inverse of this
most bad days occur because of an
overflowing inbox of small tasks that
haven't been moved into the right places
i think just like a i mean obviously
nothing's different
like i just haven't done some things but
i think i've
you know you just feel like you have
this mounting list of like little bitty
stuff that you that you forget or you're
more likely to forget stuff and someone
gives you something else to do and you
already feel behind
um
if that lists like 30 things
which i mean i don't even know how i do
it like i will easily get 20 or 30
things in that list a day just from
little bits that like
someone will say something or get an
email and forward it to that or whatever
um so do you both do that or not
and if not why not
so my
my omnifocus use
is
less sophisticated than yours
mine tends to not be i don't tend to
have things that are more than a couple
of days out and if i do
they're just in so i'll tend to just get
get tasks and do them as they come
because most of them are less than two
minutes and the only big things that i
need to do are general weekly big
routine tasks so i i don't
usually have big chunks in my inbox that
faster but
i certainly noticed that when i have a
i haven't done a weekly review
it's it's an ugly it's an ugly situation
down there
just don't want to look at it no
but if i said to you like for example
um
chris you should watch invasion on apple
tv
because you'd really like it should i
and well yeah we'll talk about that
either are we going to do a quick round
at the end with tv you should watch
invasion apple tv it's brilliant
would you not put that anomaly focus
or would you put it somewhere else would
you not have a place to put it probably
yeah i probably wouldn't have a
a place to put it
stuff that's that recreational doesn't
tend to go in omnifocus i just have a
list of stuff like stuff that people
recommend it was this was yusof's idea i
think yeah and then you put in brackets
who who
the
the jeff bezos south park episode
still on my list
like kabuki movement systems
yeah
that's my that is my kabuki movement
system is that well that's what started
the whole thing because i was like
johnny you need to watch the south park
episode this was about 18 months ago
yeah
let's see what else is on there from
yusuf
stu mcgill's mental models for success
millennials simon sinek
stephen fry on the us versus uk humor
it's weird hearing these because it's
like oh yes
video on millennials is six years old
probably still very true yeah it's
probably getting it's getting older as
well
uh so what's up
the the hack is just like it's a really
quick way if you if you keep the lists
if you use something like omnifocus or
tick tick which i imagine some people
listening to because of how much we talk
about it i think it's like the first
life hack that you have said was have a
capture process yeah so if you have a
capture process you have a list of stuff
that is date every day getting bigger
so
if you're using an app like omnifocus or
i assume ticktick then there'll be an
inbox function
each day just have a habit of zeroing it
so either like sort it or just do the
thing and if you start your day like
that
within 30 minutes you've done
several things you've already like built
this momentum with really easy stuff
you're already feeling productive
and nothing ever really gets up you
don't like forget stuff that you wanted
to remember yesterday that does go a
little bit against
do the most important biggest task of
the day first to eat the largest frog
that you can
it does
but then like how can you know what the
largest frog is if you're not clear on
all of the things on the in the place
well this would be where a good
uh
end of day
yeah process would work but the number
of people that i know who have got
[ __ ] morning routines
and absolute basic [ __ ] evening
routines pretty much it that's it's
everyone because your willpower is so
low and no one's ever actually got round
to it
and by the time you get you distracted
by whatever and this thing's just
happened
so yeah avoid overwhelm by clearing your
capture inbox is how i've
noted that okay i think it's a good it
is a good one overwhelm definitely
appears in
it's a linear relationship between how
much stuff is unsorted in your capturing
box and how much overwhelm you feel
i think the the key like side effect of
it is you end up just not you know you
put something in your inbox you think
well i'm not gonna look at that for
seven days anyway so
you like don't trust it very much which
means you use it less
it has to be time-bound a little bit
that has to be pressure yeah
if it goes in there i know i'm going to
see it again at some point yeah well i'm
going to look at it tomorrow so as long
as i know i'm going to look at it
tomorrow like i can get a system
we've talked about this off podcast
but
i recently bought something which i
thought would be really crap
i did a bit of digging looking at the
reviews and stuff and it's actually
brilliant is a cordy robotic vacuum
cleaner
so
what this does and that looking at all
the reviews there's because they all
look the same and you're like
okay are they all similar turns out
they're not they have very different
levels of
power and
um
what this is
so it looks like a disc that just goes
around your house it has two little arms
that do this
and it vacuums your house and it uses
like an ai recognition thing to to bump
into walls and make sure it covers the
entire room it's got anti-drop so if it
goes over a step it won't just fall over
into the into the kitchen and do that
it'll like
[Laughter]
it'll make its way around your house
systematically
and
it's brilliant like you can set it on a
schedule so every day
when you're out the house it just
hoovers your whole house and you come
back and you've just got
spotlessly vacuumed house
so
a few things to consider
first i had a look on aliexpress
at the options and one of them said uh
has a camera on the front but data will
not be sent to chinese government
uh will only you're like um okay if it's
specifying that
my lady doth protest too much the roomba
don't protest too much
so you just like okay i think i'll just
go
amazon for this one
um maybe not the thing to get from
aliexpress
two problems that it's hard three
problems one of them is that um
if you don't empty the bag it does a poo
so
you'll find like it'll just do a little
poo in the middle of your
living room with all the crap that it's
like compacted
um
if you leave something like a sock or a
wire around it'll get caught on the sock
and just completely like devour it
um because it's got these little arms
and then the third thing is if you don't
program it properly like i do like i
didn't is that it it started to go on
the automatic schedule at four in the
morning
and so you can just hear this like faint
you know when you're half asleep and
something's waking you up but you're not
quite awake enough and it's just like
you're like what's that he's kind of in
and out of sleep and then you hear
something go
against your door
and it's just the little thing bumping
against your room and then you're like
oh it's the [ __ ] this is come off at
four in the morning but then you you
have that battle with yourself of like
it'll finish its round soon and i'll let
it it'll go back to sleep because it
goes back to its own home again
but
it didn't for ages and then you start
for the next half an hour like i should
have just got up taking it back to its
put it back in
your house why not get a roomba
roomba is good as well but cordy seems
to be
has the best sucking power according to
the reviews how often do you need to
replace the bag or uh eight
exits that [ __ ] up
so for me in a two bedroom house that's
carpeted
every two
rounds of the house
wow so pretty frequently
quite frequently but it's it's like a
plastic thing so you just you take it
out empty into the bin put it back in
it's very quick and it doesn't like
there's no alarm or anything to tell you
it's full it just starts doing a poo
yeah right you just get to you have to
understand the tolerance of how much
how often it needs to be done and then
you get to get to know it because your
house has a lot of
things on the floor tables and cushions
and books yes and a roller and
parallettes and it's got little doors
and stuff yeah so how does it deal with
those it it can it's pretty good at like
detecting it maps out where those things
are and kind of goes underneath them i
should say as well like there is going
to be a point where once you've done
three or four rounds of your house
that you've dealt with most of the
build-up of the
the stuff and the dust and things so
the next few rounds are just top-ups
aren't they see
it's not like you have to empty the bag
so are you suggesting are you suggesting
that someone is to front load the amount
that their roomba goes and then once
you've done that you dial it back to
maintenance levels yeah blast and cruise
yeah cool cool and it'll be able to go
longer without doing a poo
yep exactly what's it called again
what's the name of it mine's a cordy
c-o-r-e-d-y
it's about 150 pounds i think
which like if anyone has a price object
i know you guys won't have a price
objection to that but
for anyone who's thinking like oh well
i'm not paying 150 quid for a hoover
like
if you were to get a house cleaner
what's that 30 40 quid per pop
you only need to use it a few times and
you've broken even on it i mean that
that being said
it doesn't do the same job as a house
cleaner a house cleaner will do
everything else this is an area of the
job of the house so i suppose it's a
little cheaper though i think
what we've got to do is say okay the
house cleaner does 40 pounds and
40 percent of that is hoovering
so then you would you calculate it based
on yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay um
i am
so this was something that someone did
to me recently and i thought it was a a
very charming way
to
do an introduction so a lot of the time
you need to reach out to someone you're
not really too sure how to do it just
send them an email do i send them a
message maybe you're contacting them on
social media
this only works for slightly less
professional things it can still be to
do with jobs or whatever but it can't
work for a proper job application uh
send someone a video introduction
so a guy reached out to me on twitter
and it was just a selfie video of him
recorded in his home office saying hi
mate i really love what you do with the
podcast just wanted to ask if you would
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
here's the thing here's the thing and
thank you very much and just sent that
and his email address and that was it
and that was all he did and it took me
50 seconds to watch while i was eating a
yogurt or something
and it was just done and it really
sorted
and it really stood out as a quite a
charming way to do it
an introduction it's very low
input from you as the person
i would still prefer overall
a short text message
i think
like a 20 sub 20 second reads three
three sentences or less but
as a change up and there's a way to
catch attention of someone maybe it's
probably better for catching attention
actually than for doing other stuff if
you're trying to maybe reach out to
someone that's a little bit above you in
the clout hierarchy
selfie video
pretty good solution
we've been getting more like video audio
outreach messages from people and like
people putting more effort into like
cold email as well
like they'll
tell a big story and
it just takes a while
to get to the critical question of like
this or not yeah what what do you want
can i delete this message
basically
so
did the video message work yes
right yep do you reply to him saying
yeah do not do not send me do not send
me videos asking for diet and training
advice that's what i said no it worked
it worked and we uh we did a we did a
thing it was good did a thing did the
thing yeah yeah success
johnny
this is another niche one but it's a for
anyone in the niche it's a banger of a
of a hack and it's also time sensitive
so when is this getting released uh
probably in a week's time okay so
if anybody owns ping golf clubs
of anything that is that qualifies
i mean i got tremendously excited about
this and you'll see why
they are giving away for free this
company called arcos
a sell these things that you screw into
the end of your club and it collects
loads of data on like all your shots and
how far they go and all sort of stuff
they sell for like 250 quid or maybe
more than that like close to 300 quid
and if you have ping golf clubs you can
get some for free completely for free
and all you do is put the serial number
in from your golf club on the website
and they send you them for free mine
just arrived today
fantastic
so if you're into that sort of thing if
you play golf you have ping golf clubs i
think you only need like one club that
qualifies you get a full set so you get
like 250 quid of the stuff completely
for free wow so this is you've got bar
tracker and club head tracker as well
yeah so it doesn't quite do the same
thing which is a bit of a shame but
um
it's like the
i think you have put it like the the
version one tech of this sort of thing
so how many trackers do you get because
you've put one ping club in and how many
have they sent you so you get 14 so you
get a full bag
for your one for every club
and then you get an app that tracks it
all and makes sense of all the data and
what does it do what's this for like
club head speed and stuff like that so
so like it'll let's say you play a hole
in golf you'll like tee off and you take
your fairway shot then you right chip
and put
it knows that all of that's happened so
it tracks a number of shots that's
that's kind of pointless because you
know that it's happened but but it tells
you how far each club's gone it tells
you when you hit your driver you fifty
percent of the time it goes slightly
left fifty percent of the time it's on
the fairway how does it know where the
ball is because you have to walk to the
ball oh so it gps's from position
launched position two so then picks up
like oh he's hit that club now he's
walked here now he's hit the next club
so log club i mean i assume log club one
has went this far
it just gives you
it then summarize it as here are three
things that you're bad at here are three
things that you need to double down on
after each round
well i i just think it's it's the way
that like probably all sports will
eventually go like smart
smart tech and like gives you data on
but do something like
my housemate is a physio for newcastle
falcons and some of the
information that the guys
i like a thing on that yeah they've got
a gps thing you've seen this
so no it plugs
it's in the back of their shirts the
rugby players playing shirts they have
the same in football as well it's a soft
tablet type thing like a a big um
bluetooth sort of tracker thing like
that but it's soft it's and it just is
gpsed up and it says
speed chronic load gps position mileage
covered that's cool all sorts of stuff i
think some of the
some of the more advanced ones it's got
g forces so for cutting and changing
directions the quickest pace that people
have cut and changed i imagine that can
like prevent against like
repeat concussion and huge surgeries
it's huge for chronic load especially in
a sport like rugby
i'm very excited about this stuff like
because you there's no
airpod equivalent that can do
heart rate and temperature and gps stuff
and through the workout stuff through
the it's like of course i don't know why
we didn't think of that in the past that
of course you can get a pulse under
temperature from the ear
so yeah i think we're getting to the
point where wearables will
they will be in the stuff that we
already use
and track they still haven't
i i still maintain that no one has
captured the wearables market
properly yet no one's done it properly
i would love to i would love to hear if
someone thinks if someone that's
listening thinks that they've got the
solution but it's not the garmin
whatever version seven of the version
eight that's just come out i don't think
that's that good the whoop is okay
but it doesn't do everything that you
need the apple watch doesn't do
everything that you need no one's got it
yet you know what's going to be awesome
about apple watch is the glucose
tracking so the 24-hour glucose tracking
but why
so is this in case we start to do carb
nite again
this is more like a medical science
perspective more than like a sort of
daily thing but i i asked a diabetes
consultant like
what do you think of this supposedly
transcutaneous laser
glucose trucking in the next generation
apple watch like is it [ __ ] and she
was like actually
it's not we can quite accurately check
the glucose from a transcutaneous blood
viscosity
laser what percentage of the population
are diabetic
pretty
type 1 or type 2
both of them need to track their glucose
presumably
it would be type 2 they don't
necessarily need to but it would be
helpful
and type 1 they definitely do
so quite a significant proportion of
people are my problem is
maybe yeah i'm just thinking this is a
very specialized use case
tracking your blood glucose as a as an
individual or as an athlete is also
helpful like if you you know the the
peter a tear ben greenfield people are
so big on this and like i think peter
tier
has glucose as like the primary
thing that he tries to operate is that
what he's bothered about he's mr glucose
i think it's up there that glucosamine
is like glute medius
in my bursa
yeah i just i can't wait for someone to
get it right and i'm surprised that
apple hasn't and because apple hasn't
yet
i don't think it's going to be them but
you said it it might like track your
glucose and all these things but you
still got to plug it in every night
tracking because you can't you can't
wear anything every day and then i've
released a new band and all that does is
like a
pulse oximeter yeah yeah
the 4.0 and it's the it's the most
highly valued
wearable in the world
what do you mean it just goes in like it
just got another round of investments
all right see the company yeah
yeah that's because they've got a
recurring model it's so clever like
they're just roping people in the
monthly recurring get yourself a
membership deal yeah
i just
berserk that isn't it berserk that a 25
pounds a month or 20 pounds a month
membership deal can piss all over an 800
quid garmin watch is how much they are
the top top top end ones i think is six
six hundred quid but it's all just
two green lights on your wrist like it's
all they're not they're not producing
better sensors it's just what's the
algorithm doing with that data yeah
and i'm amazed that apple aren't
leading the fields with it because
they're they're in that market but i
think the apple watch is weak i'd quite
like apple to win this because then it's
all just in apple house i wanted to be
part of the apple infrastructure as well
but i am i'm saddened by the fact that
they've had so many bites at the what is
it the series seven out now or the
series eight
and probably yeah they've just
how many how many iterations of this
product do you need
to try and i don't know
it's push features as well it's like oh
hey you can get a lead to ecg and a
pulse oximeter and you're like well okay
but i don't really care about those
variables like i want to be able to
[ __ ] sleep it's still going to annoy
me every time i get a message and it
goes
and buzzes in your wrist like i i'd turn
all the notifications off of my phone so
like straight away all those benefits go
yes i just i want to be able to wear it
for seven days now and plug it in there
are some of the new collard showing me
one of his new garments that he doesn't
need to i think he charges it once every
10 days
and that's pretty
it uses the screen looks a little bit
like a bat backlit e-ink type thing so
the advantage with e-ink is that it
doesn't use any energy
unless it's changing
so it sets the
uh screen and then leaves it and sets
the screen and leaves it which is much
more energy that's why kindles last for
months rather than for days yeah
but yeah that's good
club tracker deal yep yes
cool cool yes seth what you got
interesting this is another physical one
um from our good friend robbie um
so he
recommended to me
that if you're having a
let's say you're working in a annoying
organization where
you're always trying to deal with like
mistakes from payroll or hr or something
like that and the nhs
for example you know and and you
and
and you know let's say you've been
underpaid for months and months and you
you know
and so you're on the phone and you're
trying to
get something sorted and then the person
goes oh yeah fine like we'll we'll get
this done and you'll you'll get this
paid on the 20th and you go okay cool
and then you don't hear back from them
and then you email on the 20th and
you're like
i've not heard anything and then they go
well we can't see any record of it and
you know we said it on the phone and
you haven't all just all this nonsense
stuff
he says as soon as you have a phone call
you don't need to get them to confirm it
in writing
sometimes you ask them can you just send
me an email confirm it in writing and
they don't he said you can just send
them an email that says
hey thanks for the chat as discussed
blah blah blah point 1.2.3
brilliant unless they then go back and
say no i didn't say that
then you've got it in writing it leaves
the onus back on you to do that
so
just provides a bit more protection
i like the idea of providing more
protection but it i still think that you
there's enough slippage in there for a
company to get out there's culpable
deniability
that there might be i don't know better
than nothing by miles yeah and i i'm
also not sure where the law stands on
you like recording calls and things like
unless you tell someone that you're
doing it
for trading your quality purposes i
think for training and quality purposes
yeah exactly
so what would this be send a summary
email of
as discussed
uh yeah of course
as disgust
that's such a uh that's such an arcy
[ __ ] way to start an email isn't it
no one's ever received a good email that
starts with starting
pertaining to the aforementioned
conversation around the uh okay this one
so i'm going to text i'm not sure if
i've mentioned but i'm going to texas
and
this is such a [ __ ] good way to do it
a lot of the time you arrive somewhere
realize that they don't have the same
plug that you do and that you don't have
enough converter plugs you just need one
converter plug and a multi socket to
take with you so i now have
a
eight gang
five meter multi socket that lives in my
suitcase
one of those
and then you just need a single
converter and that's eight plugs that
you can use
i bet
someone listening to this
will message in and say that that is not
a safe thing to do i've done it for ages
that doesn't mean it's safe
i've not had any problems i don't know
what you're talking about i've not
encountered
and n of one here has bro sciences way
through all of these issues
it's just it's just a bit of plastic i
don't understand what the problem is i
i'm sure there's something to do with
like the us socket isn't earthed
well there's only two pins yeah yeah and
you're what you're doing is
overloading that
connection
i'd love someone to to comment if
they're watching the video or something
on some is it when you have like a
multi-socket and the fuse is only it's
for the whole thing and not for every
individual one so if you put five
kettles on it it won't blow the fuse of
the mains
but
it could be unsafely drawing too much
power from the whole
unit
i just remember i have this memory at
uni that was like really strict
on
multi-sockets and particularly for
things like kettles and so i don't know
what you're planning on plugging into it
chris i need to i need to be able to
power this so i need to take what you
see in front of you
to america
insiders inside of a suitcase
in front of you see it in front of you
yeah
the rest of us can see your bedroom if
you're going to take that and plug all
of that in that's going to be difficult
yeah so i need to take i mean what you
see in front of you yeah what i see in
front of me what you what you see
lighting me behind what you're looking
from is what you can see in front of you
this is the sam harris meditation isn't
it like turn the eye around on itself
notice that awareness itself actually
actually completely disappears um so
led two led panels a laptop a usb
sound interface
a
double usb dummy battery for the camera
uh another
uh hair light
a
snidey version of the philips hue
because i wasn't gonna fly my phillips
hue out with me uh to do some sort of
teal thing behind me
that's pretty much it it's gonna it's
gonna at least be five or six oh and the
um
laptop as well
and a toaster and a toaster and the two
kettles that i always boil at all times
and like a really unsafe cheap filament
heater
yeah one of those oil radiators that's
got the two switches on yeah thanks to a
glass of water that you keep spilling
yeah and a hair dryer
so that's
well i mean if if i burn the airbnb that
i'm staying in down you'll know why and
as will the entire internet they'll know
why yeah
dean can take that as an edit put it as
a real
yeah he'll make it as a real and that
can be my obituary
christ uh i've got more but how many
have you are we on to netflix for you
boys yet i've got i've got quite a few
things for netflix yeah okay have you
got any more have you got any more
normal ones or i i have one but it's
it's quite fresh for me but i think it's
quite a hit
so
greg knuckles
is a very well known guy in the
uh strength fighting space
not in the fighting world he's a i think
he's a power lifter but he runs
the name his website but anyway he's
just released a new app called macro
factor which is going head to head with
like the myfitnesspals etcetera
and it has some really cool features on
it
such as being able to
describe in a sentence what you ate for
a meal and it estimates the
the calories of it using ai [ __ ]
natural language recognition
some sort of machine learning thing holy
[ __ ] this is like siri for food i think
so i've never actually tried it but um
and it's all they've also just added all
of the uk barcode database to it
so it does cool stuff like
plans like tells you how much food to
eat like if you plug in your weight
and what you eat every day it just does
the rest for you um and there's a seven
day trial
in the middle of trying it
macro factor loads loads of people in
the like
the fitness world at the moment are
trying and raving about it and i think
like
as you probably know chris like well i
think maybe you're the same none of us
are that keen on myfitnesspal really no
but if you're going to try and track
your diet there's not much out there
that's really that great it's it's funny
myfitnesspal videoconferencing apps and
wearables
are three things where like there is a
kind of letter of all the evils that we
use but reluctantly and
it's where they're all so close so close
to being really good but no one's come
out and gone like this is this is how it
should be done
this seems pretty close
so i mean i've only tried it for i've
only entered a couple of days of
information but especially if the
natural language thing works
um that's crazy that's proper stephen
wolfram [ __ ] yes sir ai describe just
describe your meal by text or voice
right i'm just going to get it now
because hey siri i just ate
four bags of raisins and
a dunkin yogurt
you are over on your sodium for today
stop please stop no
no no no those aren't
they're fruit puffs okay so i typed in
like
eight ounce steak and chips and it's
estimated a portion of chips and steak
and entered it
give me give me give me a meal
um
two chicken breasts
rice
broccoli
sauce
a fresh egg
fresh egg
not an old one
yeah it must be fresh there we are
and a fresh egg
how to break the ai feature
i mean it's done at all
wow it's done at all
so
uh two chicken breasts one cup of rice
a flora one flora of broccoli
some sauce and a large
egg that's pretty [ __ ] great that's
so cool isn't it that's right it's so
good
so because didn't it wasn't
myfitnesspal wasn't it that you could
take a photo of your food and it would
try and do the same
so i think that was just a team of
people looking at the photo you're
kidding me i
i remember johnny
i don't know whether that's not
but but that is this is like that story
about those online bank online casinos
where the women are strapped to the
desks and they're forced to deal cards
until they fall asleep and there's all
those videos of them being dragged off
the set you've seen this
i haven't it's that's that's the same
level of conspiracy that you're talking
about here you know that myfitnesspal
take a photo or your food thing they've
got loads of loads of people cheering to
the desk and they just have to they're
going to identify loads of food
i've tried
overworked guy looking at pictures being
like yeah it's about that everyone's a
milestone
i've typed in big greasy pizza lol
yeah i've broken it uh shame all right
one slice of pizza but it's still giving
me an entry for pizza and it didn't
think it was funny
macro factor
has so much potential
what you got
so i've got three
do you want all three or should i should
i pick one and say save me for the yeah
exactly
okay
so
do you want a physical or a digital
johnny what you want
i want a digital
meteoromatics
is
a
service that has a calendar api for
weather
very cool so
you can
subscribe to a calendar for your city
and it just enters it as an all-day
event in your calendar with little
emojis based on what the weather's going
to be
so if you use your calendar as a day
planner
it's got the weather in there too
my only i love the idea of it my only
issue with it is how
far off the weather forecast is all the
time
to the extent that it's
you just can't place any reliance on
that
yeah i mean you mean weather forecasts
in general not not yet no no yeah yeah
in general
but i suppose like it's bet that's not
that's not a problem with does that mean
that you've got [ __ ] millions and
millions of appointments on your
calendar that are all tiny little emojis
it's a one-day event also it's not like
it doesn't give you the like breakdown
of the so it's just the day and it's the
entire day
so you have one emoji for a 24 hour
period
son so it's like an all-day an all-day
appointment at the top of ical yes and
it would be like a cloud
yeah
that's [ __ ] horseshit
is that because you want time breakdown
say how you really feel chris
chris is upset because i called his
other hack morally
is
reprehensible
this is [ __ ] payback time that's [ __ ]
that's
that's
it's [ __ ]
explain
i don't want to know what the aggregate
of all of today's weather is going to be
i want to know what the weather is going
to be at the moment that i require to
know the weather that's why the weather
changes throughout the day it's like say
oh what's the temperature going to be
next year i don't [ __ ] care i want to
know what the temperature is going to be
at the time that i require it
even if it's not
accurate well if it's not accurate then
what's the point of any of this
discussion
well yeah this is it i mean i could i
could do that i could get someone i
could get someone a
a three-year-old to just randomly hit
keys on a keyboard and go oh it's going
to be qav batman symbol today fantastic
better wear my coat
for a three-year-old is you just you
send three-year-old outside you go hey
three-year-old can you go outside tell
me if it's cold or not that is the same
level of accuracy that you're getting by
putting an emoji at the top of your ical
so i have to admit i did it for a few
days and then i disabled it
are you potentially trying to infect an
entire thousands and thousands of people
you're gonna try and infect them with
something that you've already decided
wasn't worth your time to keep a hold on
i'm palming off my life hack
yeah on to people that so what's this
that people want to avoid if they want
to make sure that they avoid it what's
it called
that's why i'm not like really defending
it that hard because i'm like well yeah
i see chris's point of like if if that
say the emoji is rain
what do you do with that information
because if you look outside it's not
raining then immediately the emojis
they're not curious well yes but it
depends if you're like oh i'm planning a
walk today
but then you what you would want to look
at is like well when is it going to rain
and where yeah what's this what's this
meteoromatics
how do you spell that
m-e-t
e-o-matics
the the sentence like qav batman symbol
i better wear my code
okay uh
final one so this was from a
three-minute monday newsletter the other
day in fact it was from today's one
which is i'll send a car
so i stole this from james smith's
manager
who i've worked with for
15 16 years and he was saying that a lot
of the time let's say that you're trying
to get someone to do a favor for you
um maybe you're trying to get someone to
come on your podcast or you want someone
to attend an event that you've got going
on or whatever it might be um
they're just not sure they're on the
fence and you need to just push them
over the line if you just tell them that
you'll send a car for them
that usually gets them past the final
hurdle so
well no so in london he would say in
addison lee which is an uber with a man
wearing a tie
um
but
anywhere else you could do probably an
uber exec
or something else but i'll send i'll
send a car for you don't worry we'll
send a car for you
it's just it flatters people enough
it removes any of the inconvenience
around transport am i going to have to
get the tube or a train or something
else you know especially if it was going
to be perhaps
a long journey a couple of hours or
whatever that you're needing to get
someone to go for if you say that you'll
send a car for them it's probably going
to cost
i don't know
100 quid an hour to get the car ish
let's say something like that but you've
locked in this person to do the thing
that you need them for now obviously
they need to be adding more value than
that but i'll send a card a good hack
the last time i was in an uber was with
chris and the
driver
got very upset that i hadn't entered
mcdonald's as the destination and chris
was very sure
that he wanted to go to mcdonald's ah
yes of course
so i like i've never really looked into
the uber app before but there's a lot of
stuff you can do right yeah stop off at
different
destinations yeah yeah and you obviously
handled it like i see did you get to
mcdonald's i ended up at mcdonald's yeah
drive-through yeah job done
uh
nine chicken nuggets because they do
boxes of six nine and twenty now nine
chicken nuggets uh
student cheeseburger because they never
check
um
a large mcchicken sandwich extra value
meal with diet coke and a cheeseburger
crunchy mcflurry yeah because you get a
free cheeseburger it's a hell of a meal
that's a big meal that chris so you've
got a meal and then some chicken nuggets
on the side then an extra cheeseburger
and then pudding
yes
something i love about the fact that if
you're in full-time education
you need a cheeseburger
that's by design and also the number
nine chicken nuggets i bet a lot of
thought has gone into that a lot of
maths yeah
no thought just analysis
yeah lots of split testing yeah not
eight not ten
it is upsetting the jump from nine to
twenty is it's too big of a jump there
should have been something in between in
my opinion but nine is six was too few
six was always too few always been too
few yeah i think nine kinds of
i think it's all right because you could
get 12 18.
okay gives you
um yeah i hadn't really thought about
you don't look i don't look at them as
like well i could get multiple i could
get more of the six options
this is just sitting down in [ __ ]
coop and you're trying to get three
quarters of a chicken all over again
isn't it
but if i change one thing about the
world like we'll leave the world a
better place it'll be to get coop to put
three quarters of a chicken on that menu
well if you get full you're getting a
whole chicken aren't you so if if you
give him some of your chicken
no no no you're misunderstanding me what
i would like you to bring me
is
taking so imaginative in a whole chicken
if that would be to be removed and given
to somebody else what i'd like is the
rest of that
brought to you what remains is my
channel
to be
mine
tries to get me on some kind of like
where are you what do you want
ghost pepper sauce remember when you ate
that sauce that we had to sign a waiver
before you had it yeah
i think you handed it really well you
were sweet
yeah you look completely unflapped by
the whole thing i didn't feel it it was
a strong sauce
it's the the dispassionate cairo driver
in me that just keeps the ball with a
straight face
so
it's the school shooter in you that
holds the handgun with the other hand
down by its side
so for reference for people listening
this
source so the scoville
unit system is
based on if you have one drop of this
sauce in x amount of water can you still
taste the chili
and then it's based on like the number
of units of water that you add to it
tabasco is 9 000 scoville units
this source that johnny and chris
made me get and sign the disclaimer for
is 15 million scoville units so it's
orders of magnitude hotter
than tabasco
it was brutal
honestly
it's like when chris got you the um
ray nephews overproof
right should we do some netflix and
stuff that we've been watching recently
yes
yes please johan that's me
um well i'll start with what i suggested
to you so this is on apple tv
and it's an apple tv original but if you
have an apple device like we're on a
year's free trial of it or something
crazy yeah um
it's called invasion
and you can just tell that they have so
you can just tell that apple are
desperately trying
to get involved in the streaming world
because everything they put out there
is so there's so much money onto it like
the production level so it's basically
a
a view on like what would happen if we
were invaded by
aliens and they were hostile
and it like plays out with like multiple
story lines across like as a soldier
there's a family there's an astronaut
that and it's really it's it's like four
episodes in it comes out every friday
really really good is this one tom hanks
no but that's also an apple original
that's just come out
but yeah it's called invasion i think
but i think with your kind of space
interest chris
i think you should like it
nice i mean i think i think everybody
will like it but it'll be on the
snidey amazon fire stick that i
absolutely don't have
yeah
if you would have it if i was to have it
this would definitely be on it
uh yousef have you watched anything
since we last spoke i actually have but
i i'm trying to frantically trying to
google the name of it oh there we
go that doesn't look like the right name
let me come back to the name of that
but the the other two
that i have seen are a film called quiet
place
oh yeah like a
horror right
yeah yeah is it with the iphone's pulled
on no that was the bird box
that's what it's called bird box really
with that
that hollywood's sandra bullock yeah
that was bird box
a quiet place so
quiet place very very good idea very
well executed and there's two films i
think they're coming out with the third
one
yeah i feel like i can't i can't give
away too much of the story because it's
um it gives it away but
um
quite old now isn't it the first one
yeah it is in fact like it doesn't give
it away because it's like it's revealed
within quite a short time that there's
these creatures on earth
that if you make a noise they run over
and kill you
right
um
the other one was it was a korean zombie
film i can't for the life of me remember
the name it's based in like ancient asia
there's a series based on it
if it's not ringing any bells we'll come
back to it
the
other one i saw is the superman film
okay so not the 1978 one how old's this
this is from 2016-ish okay
very good with henry cavill cavill
he once went into he came into the
physiotherapist that i was in human
garage in la
as i was leaving oh really you were like
are you convinced uh superman
is he is he quite big
he's very big yeah it's funny actually
the difference between like
the old chris uh
christopher reeves superman where like
now he looks like a
triathlete like a kind of guy who does
you know recreational lifter
and now
the modern superman is just absolutely
swole like just the accepted physiques
that the kind of drift over the last few
decades of what's considered the
superman physique i think that's in
bigger stronger and faster
the chris bell film where he like shows
like yeah he-man and like
uh
action man like over the years
yeah what they look like now versus oh
really
everyone everyone has been on a very
very high dose
of testosterone yeah
yes yeah
big old cycle yeah did i tell you
did i tell you about the boys
yeah
i've just finished season two of the
boys i tried i tried the first
30 minutes of it oh dude give it give it
another give it another cracks i've just
finished
season two and it was [ __ ] amazing so
if i've already talked about the boys
that's been the majority of my watching
succession
is
i've watched the first episode of that
after your suggestion we must have done
an episode
yeah we did a catch up oh we did a catch
up because i've i've now seen squid game
all the squid game okay have you watched
it did i bring up kin
no oh
kin is [ __ ] awesome so it's i want to
say hbo
production
pretty sure it's a hbo production
set in ireland
southern ireland and it's about this
gangster family it's very similar to
gangs of london
right very
very very similar to that
slightly less
um
slick a little bit who's the dude that
did the gentleman and snatch and stuff
who's that
guy ritchie yeah it's a i was about to
say lionel richie it's a lot less lionel
richie um
but it's still the same
nasty gangs fighting turf wars
it's kin ken just what it's you'll love
it k-i-n k-a-n it's got little finger
from game of thrones in it
um oh wow it's got the cast's pretty
legit yeah
awesome what else you've been watching
anything else i watched something that
started off as being like a i had like i
don't know i was like doing a bit of
work i wanted something kind of like
background on and uh it started off as
being fairly chill like a documentary
thing ended up being like one of the
most harrowing things i've ever seen
called it's on amazon called
just the sentence dave not coming back
that's what it's called okay so it's
about
a
these like guys find
these these guys could do like deep
dives down like really long so tunnel
networks and go as deep as they can like
hundreds of meters down recreationally
yeah and they did this dive and saw a
body
came back up
and committed to like and we're gonna go
back in
two years time and go we're gonna go get
that body and retrieve it and bring it
back up to the surface so this huge like
operation about how they're gonna film
it and how they're gonna how they're
gonna carry your body up there because
once you've gone that deep go you go
down in like 40 minutes but coming back
up is a 12-hour process with all the
like to avoid the bends
and uh what you see this bit on the
trailer says isn't spoiling it but
basically dave is the guy who goes to
get the body
and halfway through a guy shows just a
white ball that just says dave not
coming back on it and it's all filmed
it's all there's footage of it all
happening
it's all real and it's just like is this
underwater caves yeah so they're in like
big diving equipment like oxygen tanks
oh horrible but it's so claustrophobic
and like it's there's
actual footage of very like
uh yeah so wasn't it you that got us to
watch that one about the guy that was
lost his lifeline off the bottom of the
submarine oh yeah
last breath yeah
yeah that was terrifying as well
but this i thought was going to be like
because i quite like stuff like that
like extreme stuff documentaries thought
it was going to be a really easy chill
watch and i ended up having to like shut
my laptop and like focus on it and then
i just
watched it and used to sit there be like
well
that was that was awful
but it's good watch
like when those kids went missing in
thailand in chiang rai
and then someone made a device to
retrieve them and then elon musk called
him a pedo
yeah because he was making one
classic elon
spacex made like a or tesla made
something to go and get them oh that was
it and then the diver said that's not
gonna work no no no no no no yeah he
went and got them
sorry
have you seen what elon musk's just done
a couple of days ago the poll yes do you
see this johnny no i've not seen you
need to spend more time on twitter elon
musk did a tweet that said people keep
on talking about how
because most of his wealth is tied up in
stock for tesla and stuff um
accusing him of tax evasion
so he said
i'm just gonna dump 10 of my amazon
stock
does will that contribute to
will will you be happy if i do that for
tax reasons
yes no i don't know he's got those of
amazon stock at amazon stock sorry tesla
stock
yes no and he replies to his own tweet
and says whatever the outcome of this
poll is i'll go with it
and it ends up being i think 57 yes
20 billion
surely
that's got it is that that must be
illegal
well he can dump whatever he wants
but yeah
is it market manipulation if the people
choose he's not on the board anymore is
he is he not
yeah i mean i'm sure he's looked into it
he's probably got a lot of people
advising him he also
changed his name
on
twitter to lord edge
edgelord
what is an edgelord it's someone who
posts really
extreme memes and is a bit of a
like troll and piss taker and uh okay
like i think that kind of fits him yeah
lord it's lord lord with an e
i really like him
as long as i don't hold any tesla stock
yeah quite like it so that that's kind
of what i mean like it feels like he's
he's like taking the piss with like
you know people who get he moves the
stock price and people get stopped out
and lose loads of money and it's just
all just like bitcoin a couple of months
ago
did he yeah single-handedly
he began
the
he stopped the bull run or at least he
was one of the things that happened
that caused it to go from 61 down to 29
and now it's back to 63 or something
it's like when he feel like tweets
saying like tesla's overvalued in my
opinion whatever you're like come on man
like
the founder and you're saying stuff like
that move markets with a twitter account
yeah terrifying terrifying right boys
thank you very much for today
propanefitness.com
modern wisdom yes it is if they want to
get
just anything if you want to sell a
service as an online business
that's where they go come and be coached
by youtube properties.com modern wisdom
uh i'll see you in texas peace
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace